Speaker 1: . Let's go next to Steve from Asheville,
North Carolina.
Steve, you were on the air.
Speaker 4: David, how are you doing today?
Speaker 1: I'm doing well, thank you for asking.
Speaker 4: All right.
Thank you.
Great to be on the show.
My question for you today is, what is your
opinion of the CDC lifting these massive regulations?
Speaker 1: So I think that it's the outdoor
stuff.
I am one hundred and ten percent on board
with.
I don't even really think masks were necessary
outdoors before vaccination and certainly
with vaccination.
I think that that's beautiful on indoor hearing
here.
Here's the problem.
What you're basically saying when you say
you don't need to wear a mask indoors is you're
saying we're leaving it up to the honor system
and the concern, because when they say the
risk is to the unvaccinated, so if you're
unvaccinated, you should wear a mask to protect
yourself.
You're basically saying to people who already
weren't wearing masks, you now can just buy
sort of like pretending to be vaccinated,
not have to wear one.
And that's what seems like a concern to me.
But I think that they're trying to balance
that with wanting to incentivize as many people
as possible to go and get vaccinated.
So for like grocery stores, for example, my
instinct is it probably still makes sense
to require masks for a little while longer.
But generally speaking, these vaccines are
really effective.
And I understand that over the next two to
three months, masks are going to go away,
whether it should be today or in three or
six weeks, there's maybe a debate there.
Speaker 4: Right.
You don't think this will cause any sort of
uptick in covid cases?
Speaker 1: Oh, I think it very well might.
Among the unvaccinated who are choosing not
to wear masks.
Speaker 4: OK, I see.
Yeah, yeah.
I had an issue with, you know, the honor system,
as you mentioned.
I feel I feel people people were already not
wearing masks who didn't want to wear masks.
Exactly.
All they have to say is, oh, well, now I'm
just yeah, I'm vaccinated if it's a complete
honor system.
But what if you did you have.
Well, my issue, I have friends who work at
grocery stores and hardware stores, and it
just it seems like people who work, it's a
fatigue issue, David.
It's you know, they've been trying to force
the mass group for so long that as a service
worker, you just start to give up when you
see day in after day and of people coming
in without wearing their masks.
And now with this decision from the CDC.
Yeah.
People are saying, oh, well, we were already
having this issue.
Now people have free reign to just say, oh,
we're vaccinated.
It's I think it's a mess.
Speaker 1: But they're not actually in the
position of saying to customers, are you vaccinated?
Right.
I mean, it's just it's assumed that if you're
not wearing a mask, you've decided you don't
need to because you're vaccinated.
Or are you saying some of them are in positions
of having to ask customers if they're vaccinated?
Speaker 4: Oh, it's an honor system.
So you should be assumed.
It should be assumed, I think.
Yeah, there's a degree of concern of people
who, you know, are worried of someone who
is not vaccinated coming into the store without,
of course, asking.
A lot of people think that that's the concern.
Speaker 1: Well, I expect to see employees
at many chains and businesses continue to
wear the masks longer than the customers.
That's enough to be clear, you
Speaker 4: know, no, it's it's it's definitely
it's going to take some adjusting.
You know, I'm at my place of business.
I decided I would not wear my mask.
I'm vaccinating myself and I felt naked.
Right.
And it's like not wearing a shirt.
It was it's very a very weird feeling.
Speaker 1: Humans adapt to so many things.
And in 14 months of mask wearing for the people
that have been doing it, you don't just get
unaccustomed to it.
In a day there will be an off ramp.
And I think there will be some challenges
with it.
Speaker 4: Right.
Of course.
I mean, I was able to adjust to the microchip
that was implanted in me, of course.
So so
Speaker 1: that's easier because it's so small,
it's easy to adjust
Speaker 4: it.
Yeah, it's a joke,
Speaker 1: by the way, you know, because of
what happens right now, that is a complete
joke.
Please don't demagnetize or cancel me or anything.
All right, listen, I'm going to go before
you say more things that get me in trouble,
OK?
Speaker 4: I apologize.
Speaker 1: All right.
Take care.
I love Asheville.
Great place.
Never been there, but love it just from what
people have told me